hi GQ I'm the kid ly and this is my
tattoo
[Music]
tour just turned 18 when I got this
tattoo this right here is my homie sake
who passed away and I always like wanted
the first one to be something that was
meaningful or you know not something
that I'm going to regret after like a
couple months I could never regret
getting him tattooed on me so it was
actually like the least painful like
tattoo I have on me I couldn't believe
that I was getting a tattoo cuz the
anticipation of like getting one
everyone was like dude they Hur so much
it sucks getting one and I remember
getting this and being like are are you
guys doing it yet and they were like
it's already in motion then we have a
mum tattoo this is like a like sailor
style tattoo everyone always points out
that it's muum instead of M cuz I
usually like the classic tat is like M
but like I'm Australian so I just put
the U I didn't think anything of it but
everybody always points it out and like
laughs at me for this is an alien giving
a chocolate chip cookie back to its
craft it's like it's UFO and the meaning
behind this is cuz like me and my family
have always been super into like aliens
and like conspiracies and like stuff
like that an alien like comes down to
earth and it's just like this place is
terrible this place sucks but we did
find this one thing it's called a
chocolate chip cookie and it is
incredible so here it is this is a a
girl holding on to a spider and this one
actually is the only one on my whole arm
that just has no meaning it was a cool
picture my ex-girlfriend found sent it
to me and I was just like this is cool I
want to get tattooed on my hand and I
just got to tattooed on my hand this one
right here it's like a world and
symbolic for my homie juice just cuz
like juice W and cuz it was like right
after I got my boy sake and um I was
trying to figure out like a cool way cuz
you know obviously didn't necessarily
want to fill out my body with a with a
bunch of portraits of of my homies so I
was like what's like a cool little way
that is something that just for me that
I can know like okay I have that that
have that with me and that was the most
painful tattoo like hands down still to
this day I had the hand I've had knees
I've had like my ribs everything and
like that is by far the most painful
tattoo of all time I have this one right
here it's a funny story it's one of my
proudest proudest stories maybe it's a
stick figure Cowboy that has angel wings
and is wearing clogs and it was drawn on
me by post Malone it wasn't our first
time ever ever meeting but like it was
our first time I think propably like
hanging hanging out and we had this idea
of tattooing each other and he's
actually a pretty good tattoo artist it
was a whole freestyle just off the Dome
he was just coming up with this as as he
as he went he was just like all right
I'm going to jistic figure and now he's
going to have clogs and we're going to
put a cowboy hat on him and so it ended
up with this because I was really proud
of it post is a very big inspiration for
me I took it apart myself one night I
was like yo can you also just point an
arrow to this and just say po alone did
this cuz I just thought it was like I
just wanted that to to be a to be a
memory for me I tattooed him too that it
wasn't as flattering as this one he's
like yo hurry up I need to I need to go
to the bathroom I was like okay I
don't know what to do so I just tattooed
on his kneecap like a sad face and then
with the woods um I have to
underneath cuz he needed to I
guess my homie cie Drew this he drew
this on a piece of paper if I my end of
the world tour much the tour was my
first ever tour and I was just like you
know what it I'm going to get it
tattoed on my knee and then we all got a
tattooed on our KNE Central C just
tattooed this one on me when we show the
music video for the song that just came
out this one right here just wanted to
get a tattoo right here for some reason
just s it look cool my homie Dev found
this it's just like a little Thorn thing
going on this was just like a random
little love heart I got it at like a
birthday party but I think I just wanted
to feel how it would feel to get a rib
tattoo I don't really know why I decided
to get that but it's there and then this
one right here on my ribs is really cool
this is like a little kitten holding a
mushroom to make a long story show all
of us who are on the Europe tour the
first Europe tour got kitten tattoos uh
and holding different things so like my
kin's holding a mushroom glaive got a
kitten that was holding a piece of
clothing because um he lost all of his
clothes my homie TJ got two kittens
playing playing pingpong and that was
cuz um I was wiping him in pingpong that
whole uh tour so this my homie cie
actually Drew this just the world Towers
just reminds me of home what's next dude
probably better get out of here go get
some food what's the next tattoo
oh oh dude I'm fried my next tattoo I
have no clue this was kid Le Roy
thank you for tuning in please check out
my album
bye